I think there are a great group of
strong women and have strong opinions
and and I love that and they might fight
a little bit like sisters but they still
support each other and I love that well
Denise Richards told me earlier this
week she has been a fan of The Real
Housewives for a while and she's in a
good place so why not join the beauties
of Beverly Hills should be fun for her
Beverly Hills is my favorite Housewives
I'm very excited for this and as et
onlines lauren zima found out so was
housewife favorite Lisa Vanderpump miss
Richards is joining the cast how do you
feel she's fitting in to always switch
these things up she's really is about
dog rescue so that was kind of a bonding
moment for the two of us a well known
animal lover Lisa's also famous for her
restaurant empire for in the LA area her
Bravo hit Vanderpump rules follows some
of her wild staff two of its stars Tom
Schwartz and Tom Sandoval and Lisa just
opened the sleek and steamy bar eatery
called
Tom Tom everything about Tom Tom is out
of the ordering it the clock goes
backwards so you sit back up Tony get
younger look at these chandeliers we're
first inside the elaborately decorated
outdoor indoor West Hollywood hot spot
where Lisa was still in boss-lady mode
have you guys stepped it up even more
yeah I feel like we definitely have a
mean uh tell them we've been well tell
them we've been a little casual trip to
Mexico it was a non-refundable trip we
had together hopefully they're in sync
on some future competition
[Applause]
[Music]
Lance Bass is opening a bar just on the
streets so oh I just see a little look
on your face well we welcome him Lance
Bass is one of my dearest dearest
friends and it's gonna be radically
different so I think the more the
merrier okay but what about this
competition overseas get ready
Lindsay Lohan has a new reality show
where she's putting together clubs in
Greece and she has been compared to you
I don't think that where that said have
you given her any advice no I haven't
hasn't asked for any maybe she should
[Music]